hello reject nation
it's Greg Alva here she warden Ross my
old buddy who I met when I was like 14
years old came on this channel one time
forever ago we've officially known each
other for half of our lives now that is
true holy [ __ ] that's weird
that's a long time yeah well buddy he
has a channel called cinematix which is
doing really great right now he has some
really unique topic videos on there I'm
telling you guys this channel worth
checking out this guy really knows his
stuff he just did a collab with koi Shan
genre you know the fast-talking guy from
Boston Bluff and he's done a lot of
stuff man this guy has a great great
child way better than ours you should
check it out as soon as you can
Oh shucks no he didn't even deny that
yeah that's true well I wanted to show
you a video today from one of my
favorite channels what culture they do
these awesome list videos okay they had
this list video I feel like you and I
will probably know what these movies are
yeah be fun to talk about them anyway
ten movie sequels you didn't know we're
coming in cool I'm sure we've heard of
this one but let's check it out anyway
[Music]
wizards and third popular tropes get
buried so let's unearth some of them
together shall we now warning you might
not care about any of these but I'm just
presenting the facts so don't shoot the
attractive bearded messenger apparently
with this in mind I'm Jules Walker
common these are ten movies
emotional explosion and the biggest
entry in the franchise story is a
mystery and the good years ago in fact
all we know is that the film's title
must not be set in stone as revealed in
a Twitter altercation between spongebob
showrunner bit s'en aller
and yahoo entertainment well we know
that and it'll also be released in
August 2019 in a slot which sees it
being the only animated film of that
month making it an even bigger license
to print money for the seven men in
black for a very burning in people yeah
I don't think it is but will be set in
the same world as the first three but
not have
I don't know if that one counts seems
like everything that's been set up so
far great all the way and aren't made
throughout Iron Man and Punisher under
their belts and we'll have Steven
Spielberg as the executive producer
expect that rumored men in black jumps
now this is a success the mistakes video
game adaptation populated by the likes
of Assassin's Creed and Super Mario Bros
it's not a huge price their roles which
is usually a sign of how much space do
you do have to see we care about Angry
Birds anymore corners so we'll see how
this one turns out because I mean seeing
the first one I'm a busy man on a single
dad and four channels to support thank
God now you see me was a surprise hit
but its sequel now you see me too was a
gross disappointment oh yeah where the
first was enjoyable stylish and such
such a great care a second was
repetitive convoluted and overly
self-indulgent they were dragged out to
the book where all the reveals raised
nothing more than disinterested grunts
from the audience so is a bit of a shock
to see it gets another sequel a sequel
this room to have Benedict Cumberbatch
in it which will certainly get tongues
working as well that's why than before
they're not job three there's a lot of
enemies even we can't blame you because
about ten percent on Rotten Tomatoes
which is a direct reflection of its
quality and should be avoided as if it
were a bullet not that much yes but it
was unintentionally
earlier this year crossing over to the
[Music]
okay number two reign of the Superman
reign of the Superman is the only set on
this list to not have the original film
released yet unveiled at this year's San
Diego Comic Con 2018 will see the
release of death of Superman an animated
movie that will bring Superman's epic
clash with doomsday to the screen after
it was recently seen in Batman vs
Superman de correo director epic novel
animation all 2019 reign of the Superman
will follow and since it's based on the
comic book of the same name we already
know quite a lot about the story that's
good Superman for new heroes emerge each
of them claiming to be Superman the Man
of Steel a hammer wielding former
weapons designer the man of tomorrow
also known as the cyborg superman the
metropolis hit a teenage clone of
Superman Krypton straight-to-dvd won the
reign of the Superman is a Kurisu male
holding giant robot battle suits
missiles and widespread destruction
might be my most anticipated source
material but if it's faithful fans who
haven't read the comic will be able to
witness one of Superman's best stories
in gorgeously rendered computer
[Laughter]
this time around though the action will
take place in Brazil took place in
Mexico and will follow a group of girls
holiday in a coastal Mora girls under
water roads in pretending to be Lara
Croft they go there and try to get them
when they arrive they discover that
those words aren't quite as uninhabited
given how the first film ended it's not
very clear which characters would be
able to make a comeback if any while
delivering on the gory kills as always
you soon well thanks well they were
wrong there were a few start off with
one that we definitely knew about John
wick chapter 3 I actually just showed my
girlfriend part 1 & 2 in the span of two
weeks and I'd like John wick chapter 2 I
really don't prefer it I don't it's
really just like rock and roll John wick
yeah yeah and the emotional stakes don't
feel as high yeah there it's just
nowhere near as of a personal movie and
it really is a film that's like more
about having fun it doesn't even feel as
dark part 2 doesn't feel necessary to me
until the last half hour yeah exactly
when everything goes to [ __ ] for this
poor do you know so I'm curious to know
how they do part 3 because I did hear
once one of the writers talking about he
has his own story idea where he's kind
of a wanderer in Japan yeah I thought it
might be cool to do a story that's maybe
more immediate like okay sup right after
the second one so I was trying to get
out of New York immediately because he
says at the end of part
that he only has an hour until the
contrary yeah again she can't get very
far especially because part two just
made it freakin bananas re-watching part
two made me realize even more like wow
they just really went all crazy in to
ridiculousness
yeah like everyone's a hit man this
world is crazy you go shopping for guns
like it's Kings right yeah it's just so
much sillier by the time it gets to part
two so I'm hoping for part three they
can bring it back a little bit more to
that grounded realism exactly and a
little more subtlety that part one hat
of course still expand your world but I
think an immediate tale can be a more
personal tale - yeah I agree I'm
definitely excited about it though like
it's cool yeah the actions awesome it's
bigger and more exciting but like you
said I don't think the sequel was
necessarily better they can keep getting
bigger and more exciting but just bring
more emotional stakes and and yeah make
it feel more intimate and personal like
the first one but when I compare the
first and second one I think the biggest
difference comes down to how they handle
act 1 because I'm act 1 there's no
action until like 25 minutes into the
movie or something yeah so when it kicks
in you're like whoa [ __ ] the action here
is freaking intense and awesome and part
2 is just like minutes yeah so I'm
hoping Part III can give us a really
good immediate and personal tale once
more agreed
Shaun the Sheep movie - honestly most of
his animated movies I just haven't seen
I wanted to see Shaun the Sheep because
I like chicken run I like Walt Ramat but
I did not catch this one spongebob
though do you watch the show do i watch
the spongebob did you watch oh did I
yeah kid yeah my daughter doesn't watch
it but I didn't even really know that it
was still like on and they were saying
it has to be almost 20 years it's a long
time yeah I didn't even know there was a
second spongebob movie so I liked the
first one the first one I thought was
really was that live action now the
second one so where they go and I made
it into live-action world it see I guess
I got shot was the first one and I never
knew about the actual yeah there's a
second when they were showing us and
which is ha freaked me out
it's touching me get off you can't be in
the video today I don't remember people
responding so well to the second one so
I think for the third one they have to
make it just an animated movie yeah I
don't ever really respond well to a
whole spacejam type of method you know
where you bring live-action into real
life that's fine for like an episode if
you do some of my bad
don't do it for a whole movie we show
for the animation although Framed Roger
Rabbit is the exception it's different
if that's the introduction yeah you know
but you do the sequel and do that I'm
like it's a fun experiment ultimately we
show up because we're fans of the
animated show yeah
men in black for what is this now I
thought it was a really yeah like a
reboot I wasn't sure if it was a soft
reboot or like completely redoing the
franchise but it's definitely not a
sequel Tommy Lee Jones and Will Smith
aren't coming back from what I've heard
but it's like a same universe like yeah
agent JK exists in this universe but now
we're just focus on different people
about they were recasting and restarting
all over it yeah I didn't know they were
gonna still continue the storyline just
in a separate part of this unit yes
whether it's a soft reboot or whatever
who would you pick for the two stars of
this movie I already have mine in mine
or yours
okay so watching the Golden Globes three
larsson and Lupita Nyong'o Krishnan
award together and they had such great
chemistry and there is an issue with the
teleprompters so they were like making
jokes about it and they were awkward and
cute and funny and I think that they
would be awesome so us our email reboot
this my wife's Buster's bad boy hey you
know there'd be some guy agents in there
too but I just loved their chemistry and
I think with the right people involved I
think it could be really really good Wow
I would get angry birds movie I remember
seeing the trailer and actually being
like this looks pretty funny but then it
came out too abysmal reviews but I said
it's one of those things that where I
think I should still give it a chance
there's all Netflix I think oh is it
yeah well I have the app and I think
there's a great storyline love to watch
the movie good to me Angry Birds is
already setting itself up
yeah be hated yeah because it's a game
based on an app so I feel like people
already have sold themselves they're
gonna go watch the movie to hate it
yes ran it I haven't seen it so I don't
know for sure if that's the case and
it's just a flat-out terrible movie
because
watching the trailer and actually
laughing at stuff that's funny I never
saw the movie I remember there's a few
moments that I chuckled in the trailer
but you brought up a good point we were
watching it like who cares about Angry
Birds anymore
yeah like the movie did well at the time
cuz people still had the app and I'm
like the hospital plays with the app
even when the first one came out that
was dying
yeah people weren't really playing it as
much by the way he said it might be the
best video game movie what do you think
is the best videos on BET Mortal Kombat
yeah I would say cuz it's not based on a
video game but wreck-it Ralph and Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world there's video game
styles they're not like based on an
existing video game poll we gotta wait
for Tomb Raider Joe ever songwriter yeah
now you see me three so weird formula
they're doing here getting actors who
are known to play other magicians yeah
yeah you seen icing me too
yes is that one I agree completely what
they said here it's overconfident
ridiculous it's way to roll your eyes at
every twist yeah it was way too overdone
and I mean down Radcliffe look like he
was having fun good I was about to say
that because he is someone that ever
since Harry Potter cuz I felt like he
was the weakest actor of the three like
friends in Harry Potter but after he's
gone on to like pick really interesting
yeah roles and really push himself and
challenging himself as an actor he's my
favorite part of that movie easily yeah
he's having the most fun and he brings
something unique to the table yeah film
I think adding Benedict Cumberbatch
weirdly does intrigue me yeah like that
guy seemed and that franchise would
actually be a lot of fun for me he's one
of the few MCU actors where I just
associate him as Benedict Cumberbatch
yeah you know there's other MCU
characters around all the time
Captain America there's Hemsworth is
Thor exact Benedict Cumberbatch's
Benedict Cumberbatch because I feel like
the excitement of Daniel Radcliffe and
now you see me too was exciting to like
Harry Potter guy in the magic movie you
know and I guess that's probably the
same type of anticipation they're trying
to gather for now you see me through a
new cast him I'm just excited to see
Benedict Cumberbatch along with a huge
yes like that I agree we should put up
Hugh Jackman and Christian Bale and the
fourth yeah because that's what they're
known for
yeah okay this movie crossing over I saw
this with John in the theater I thought
their first is the Liam Hemsworth me
I saw this with John an advanced
screening years ago and it's a movie
that is very much wanting to be crash
its multiple stories instead dealing
with racism which it does because it's
about stuff yeah it's about people
dealing with immigration a bunch of
different story lines yeah it's nowhere
near as strong or as effective it's kind
of a weak film good concept it sounds
like I think to do a sequel sounds
stupid no money you know 3.5 million
worldwide
no don't call it part 2 this reboot I'd
take this concept because it's a cool
concept and its really timely especially
right now take that concept and just do
it with better execution call it
something else like dreamers No yeah
yeah speaking of that they're rebooting
party of five and a new CEO but they're
doing it with the Hispanic family whose
parents get deported and now the five
kids have to try to keep their lives
going while their parents are back in
Mexico trying to make it back to them so
it's actually really an interesting
concept for a reboot and this kind of
reminded me of that
like crossing over reminders you party
this one does sound cool the reign of
the Superman I was just talking with
Jordan about this before I was saying
tonight I want DC for live-action films
I think it's saving course they could
have do some live action direct graphic
novel adaptations that's something I
think that would really help save these
guys yeah there's some graphic dolls
that are just huge that would be so cool
to see adapted Batman year one the long
Halloween death of Superman but it
sounds like these are part of the Warner
Brothers animated films yes the ones
that go straight to DVD but are for the
most part are pretty damn good yeah to
see the reign of Superman
that sounds pretty sweet I really want
to start giving these movies like more
limited release yes lekha theaters like
sony's doing with into the spider-verse
yeah do that with these movies because
we have raised every smart and
spider-verse looks amazing the animation
is beautiful give them really big
budgets to like go all out
I feel like more animated superhero
movies would be a really interesting way
to go and into the spider-verse might
make that start happening if it is done
but it does well yeah if it is done well
might be the best Sony produced
spider-man in recent years a cool part
about what you're bringing up with
Spider versus a great point because
that's focus on Miles Morales yes here
it's not
focus on Clark Kent a Superman it's
focus on these other people who dawn the
Superman mantle that's exciting to me to
see the other characters portraying the
famous hero we haven't really gotten
that yet we've got a shit-ton a Peter
Parker's you've got a bunch of Clark and
I mean Clark Kent does come back but of
course you know they would be cool to
see this I want this franchise to go on
as long as possible I would love it if
they actually try to connect this as I
know doing like a completely separate
story I know this is one more meter yeah
for some reason these shark franchises
just keep going like that like they had
an open water to their I think they've
had like three or four Watchers yeah
open water open water to a drift in open
water three cage dive and it came out
last year so it was like basically the
same thing as 47 meters down I mean the
title alone just makes it sound so bad
yes so stupid and I feel like 47 meters
now could have had a little bit more fun
yeah hopefully they take that approach
especially when you're giving us a title
48 meters
yeah it's not the same as doing like
Ocean's Twelve or or a hundred two
Dalmatians yeah I do like the fact that
they're gonna be in the ruins which is
kind of cool and the environment sounds
cooler yeah yeah exactly there's more
possibilities I feel like that way yeah
there could be pockets of air you know
that we go to go diving in [ __ ] like
that I mean it sounds are gonna trying
to go bigger like this secret place I
think what was relatable about the first
one was there's a constant that people
just do like they go diving in water and
then oh my god they're not too far
there's all these sharks now this one
sounds a little bit more ridiculous so
I'm hoping they are aware of that yeah
ridiculous like a long yeah and just go
all let's go all I just have a lot of
fun with it that would be the saving
grace that thing and no offense to Mandy
Moore she seems like an amazing person
every scene she was in especially like
the really emotional scenes I couldn't
help but laugh in the theater because I
didn't buy any of them so maybe I don't
know when the casting maybe get a you
know larceny and I will see it I'll be
opening night well guys thanks for
tuning in thank you what culture for
providing another great list video for
us to discuss right here you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bella get notified every
time one of our videos is out Jordan
Ross you can follow him at cinematics on
YouTube Twitter you have Instagram
instant really pull sign-in scream that
much but yeah Facebook and at the Jordan
Ross I post a bunch of stuff on there
too mainly cinematics YouTube channels
I'm subscribed to them they're a feature
channel on us so make sure to go
subscribe to these guys right away a
link in the description box seriously
has some awesome movie topics on there
that he covers some unique videos too
thanks man go check it out yeah